you've been talking somewhat about
Donald Trump hard not to these days
what's our opinion about in President
Trump
oh sweet Jesus well you know it's like
everyone's waiting for this moment for
him to become presidential you know
they're like oh he has to learn how to
control his emotions he has to learn to
be measured you know but the man is 17
years old those are things that you
teach kids I'm teaching my
seven-year-old those things right no
Trump is seven he's not gonna learn and
now yeah I'm guessing you're not a Trump
fan then you wouldn't say you're a Trump
fan I am so not a Trump fan he annoys me
his whole family annoys me bad a fan
yeah a friend of mine was at the movies
and he goes Oh guess who was here
Tiffani Trump was here with Secret
Service Tiffani Trump Tiffani Trump was
there with Secret Service that annoys me
that Tiffani Trump has a Secret Service
detail what the hell is she doing with
Secret Service I know who she is
you don't know she I have to say it
would take me a second to even know what
she look exactly so why do I have
secrets she should get a mall cop that's
what she
if someone every teacher that side since
never dude on a Segway just follow it
all around that's it don't even like
them never has around
you